if you think that  being a feminist makes you any less of a  man  you're admitting that your version of  masculinity  requires the oppression of women  [Music]  uh what no it requires the oppression of  you you're someone who should be  oppressed for the good of mankind as a  male feminist or maybe simply ejected  off of the earth and uh and into the  void of space i don't know i'm fine with  that conflict i mean that works too  anyway does being a feminist make you  less of a man uh of course it does  because men are meant to be strong  they're meant to be leaders and by  calling yourself a feminist you're  proudly showing off not only your  intellectual moral weakness but your  collectivist mentality as well so yes  that makes you that makes you certainly  less of a man